Neil: So do you you count yourself as having geek street cred?
Trevor: I don't know what geek street cred is. I feel like geek and street don't mix. Geek lab cred?
Trevor: You know what...
Neil: In South Africa did you have science teachers?
Trevor: I did. I had one of my favorite teachers
and probably my best teacher was my
science teacher Mr. Pilate and he was... he
just made everything seem simple like he
You know you know when those teachers can teach you a thing like
Neil: Not all teachers can do that!
Trevor: And he... I would get better marks at
science than I would at most subjects
and I think it was just he made me
understand what it was all about.
Neil: That's good, yeah that's good. So then you became
a comedian. Apparently he wasn't influential enough!
Trevor: Well, what happened actually was my math
teacher was horrible and because he failed me,
Neil: That cancelled out...
Trevor: No, and then I couldn't I couldn't go and
study in university I couldn't do
because in South Africa if you
don't do math you can't do science
anymore and so because I failed at math they basically went "you fail at science"
and I used to get an "A" for
science. I could have been you.
Neil: But, see, math is the language of the universe.
Trevor: So what I was speaking
was a dialect? How does that work? I was
passing at science that's all I know and
you just sent me back. I couldn't speak a
language of the universe.
Neil: So you went the comedian track instead of the
scientist track.
Trevor: Yes.
Neil: That's good, but how about just general geek, are you a geek sympathizer?
Trevor: I don't know. I feel like geeks run the universe look at you! You have your number one on the
book selling list! Geeks are running
Silicon Valley, running TV shows.
The richest people in the world! I don't
think you need sympathy if you're a geek
now. I feel like it's the other way
around because imagine if you are on the
cusp of geek vs. jockness. Yeah right
those are time when jock was everything.
Neil: Yes, and they give us wedgies.
Trevor: Right, and then what happened was geek all of a sudden tipped that.
Neil: Yeah, because the jocks needed us to fix their computers.
Trevor: But now imagine if you were jock
just pre-tech boom, like and then you just
just jocked at the wrong time.
Neil: Oh that'd be bad.
Trevor: Imagine that.
Neil: You're homeless now.
Trevor: Now you're struggling and then you're like man I
used to give that guy wedgies.
Neil: I'd like that verb - jocked at the wrong time.
Trevor: Yeah, you jocked at the wrong time. You could have geeked at the wrong time.
You could have geeked in the dark ages! That's the wrong time to geek.
Neil: Total wrong time to geek.
Trevor: The worst time to geek!
Imagine you trying to be a scientist in the dark ages.
Neil: No, I'd be burned upside down at the stake.
Trevor: And just because you were black, mostly. That would it be like
most of it and then they'd be like oh
yeah and he was a scientist. I don't even
know what that was! I'm glad we burned
him.
Hey, did you like that? Cool video, huh?
Well how about a bunch of cool videos,
all commercial free, plus exclusive
original content that you can't find
anyplace else all on StarTalkAllAccess.com